it is the Monday right before 83 starts
and we've had a day full of press
conferences so let's talk about the
biggest things we learned in today's
roundup brought to you by Qualcomm
Snapdragon LTE modems or epically bast
LTE speeds xbox had two massive
announcements today the first was that
they are indeed planning to release a
model of the xbox one that is forty
percent smaller called the xbox one s
later this year and they're also
releasing a new console called Project
Scorpio which will run at six teraflops
and deliver true 4k gaming microsoft
confirmed that all games and peripherals
will be compatible across the two new
consoles and the original Xbox one the
publisher also revealed their Xbox play
anywhere program which enables those who
bought the game on either xbox one or PC
to play it on the other platform for
free confirm games that are a part of
the program include dead rising for
Gears of War for forza horizon 3
scalebound and state of decay too
unfortunately both Sniper Elite Four and
crackdown 3 would delay today but
Ubisoft cushioned the blow with big
gameplay reveals for the new southpark
game watch dogs too for honor Ghost
Recon wildlands and a brand-new
open-world action sports game called
steep be sure to head to gamespot for a
comprehensive overview of all the things
that happened today and I will have your
Tuesday wrap all ready to go for you
this time tomorrow catch you then
you